they've been arriving by email the value
of the fine is 50 pounds now we don't
have the names the identities of the
individuals that have been fined you'll
remember that the metropolitan police on
wednesday said that they were finding in
the region on tuesday finding the region
of 20
issuing about 20 different fines now we
do understand that some of these fines
were connected to an event on the 18th
of
june 2020 now that was the leaving do of
a senior high profile
number 10 official
now at that kind of event you can
imagine all sorts of senior figures
particularly from the civil service
likely to have dropped in on that event
so there could be some relatively senior
officials as well as potentially more
genie ones at that event the police
appear to be pursuing a strategy of
picking off the low-hanging fruit those
people who perhaps filled in their
questionnaires and admitted that they
were breaching the rules put in place to
try and curb covid at the height of the
pandemic which these events seem to have
been in breach of uh but the police not
yet
issuing fines to high-profile political
figures as far as we know
or people who might contest
what happens
it does appear as if the police are in
discussions with the crown prosecution
service who would have to put up a
lawyer if any of these individuals
appealed the decision
and that it would all end up in a
magistrates court those cases more
difficult cases well frankly those fines
haven't been decided uh or issued by the
police uh but the first fines for the
easier cases do appear to have been
landing by email earlier today
uh and some the question of course how
it could have taken so long for us to
get to this stage where 50 pound fines
are being are being handed out
that's right and it has been complicated
for the police and i think when the cps
go through with the police how this
investigation has ended up in the state
that it is there'll be lots of questions
like why did it take so long for the
police to get involved in the first
place when there was clear evidence
potentially of a breach in the rules uh
that was ignored by the police there'll
be questions about whether those
questionnaires that have been issued to
more than a hundred people soliciting
information about what went on in
whitehall at the height of the pandemic
with the right way to proceed really the
cps's job is to sort of dot the eyes and
cross the t's to make sure that there's
no chance if they can possibly prevent
it of a appeal being successful as it
were the cps had to do due diligence on
the police's work and that began only
belatedly i understand it wasn't uh the
cps weren't consulted at the start of
the investigation uh in quite the way
that some thought it should have been
but now the cps are going through how
the how the police have done their
investigation uh potentially have the
power to uh direct them to do a bit more
work to copper bottom the case before
the fines are issued that i think is the
reason why this is taking longer than
many expected